aux portes de l'ukraine les exercices
militaires russes se poursuivent chaque
jour la russie continue de renforcer ses
positions selon washington plus de cent
mille soldats sont massés à la frontière
depuis plusieurs semaines dans une
interview exclusive accordée à france 24
le secrétaire d'état américain anthony
blinken sonne à nouveau lé alerte
une agression dès cette semaine est tout
à fait possible quand on voit ce qui se
passe autour de l'ukraine avec le
déploiement des forces russes on retient
toute hypothèse pour avancer la
diplomatie mais dans un premier temps ça
dépend entièrement de la russie de son
côté la russie qui a déjà un excellent
akrimi en 2014 affirme qu'elle n'a pas
l'intention d'envahir l'ukraine
pour le ministre des affaires étrangères
sergueï lavrov
il est encore temps de trouver une issue
diplomatique à la crise
nous mettons en garde contre les
conversations interminables sur la
résolution de problèmes qui doivent être
résolus aujourd'hui mais néanmoins en
tant que ministre des affaires
étrangères je dois dire qu'il ya
toujours une chance
pour éviter toute escalade moscou exige
que kiev renonce à adhérer à l'otan une
condition inacceptable pour les
occidentaux où tu veux empêcher
l'ukraine d'avoir sa souveraineté son
intégrité ne veut à sa porte qu'un
s'absenter dire qu'on est à croupion la
demo poutine ne veut pas de pays qui
soit à même de choisir ses choix de
l'alliance l'allemagne comme la france
tente également de peser dans les
discussions
après une rencontre en ukraine avec le
président zelensky le chancelier
allemand olaf scholz doit rencontrer
vladimir poutine à moscou ce mardi